oh I got to go on Joe Rogan this week we
went on Joe Rogan and Joe Rogan's you
know it's I was nervous first of all you
know I was nervous because I look up to
Joe so much you know and for some reason
with me I think when I look up to
somebody it for some reason it makes me
kind of nervous
you know I guess well you wanna I don't
know it's like when you're hanging out
you know what it feels like to me a
little bit it's like you're hanging out
with your big brother and his friends
and you're like you wanna you know
you're just I don't know I was just
nervous but it was it was wild man and
right off the bat Joe Joe start stalking
me and I love Joe you know I'm extremely
grateful to him you know he's done a lot
of nice things small things that were
really nice for me like out of the aah
like he would just see me do comedy and
I've said this before but he would just
drop me a text a couple days later the
next day and just say hey man you had a
really good set you know and uh and that
kind of stuff like you don't realize
sometimes like somebody that you had my
or like you know telling you something
pop sharing something positive
supporting what you do you don't realize
how much that means to that person and
he doesn't you know I don't think he you
know he doesn't probably realize it but
it's like I would get those texts and
I'm like wow man you know it's like your
big bro it's like I don't know it's just
like you're it's like impressing your
brother impressing I don't know you know
and that kind of stuff really just rez
has resonated with me over the years
he's done that and Joey Diaz does that
as well he'll call you but but Joe would
do that sometimes and just hit me up and
say hey man you were really funny last
night and you know coming from you know
my life when all I wanted to do probably
was you know make make people I admired
you know make them feel like or make
them feel like I was part of
I was okay you know maybe some of that
goes back to like father and brother you
know not being present growing up and
all of that but you know just when you
have a you know when you have a male
figure in it you know just that support
support that's really what it is Joe's
been so supportive and so you know
anyway but you know I was excited to be
in there and I was excited to get to
hang out with him because he thinks like
wild you know he's like he thinks like
he's got you know it's like I think he
has more than one brain in his head you
know Joe Rogan might have five or six
brains in there and one of the brains is
probably a rat you know and then he's
play he might have other brains orbiting
around brains you know he might have one
brains it's you know he might have
brains in the distance you know cooking
elk I mean he's got you know he just he
continues to kind of like expand his way
of thinking and so right in the
beginning he was talking about infinite
and infinite uh if there were infinite
universes and if there were more than
just one of you and I couldn't even I
was so nervous kind of I was just
couldn't even think really that good and
but then now I'm thinking after that I
texted him the next day I was like manna
I'm obsessed now with wondering if there
are infinite universes so many so this
is what he was saying as so many
infinite universes that if you there
would be a possibility for you to meet
your exact self like you know say the
two universes get close enough to each
other somehow in orbits or whatever and
then you you know there's you know
programs you're both astronauts or
something you meet like if you were to
able to meet your exact self think about
that if you were able to meet your exact
self
and I was just like I left there
thinking what I like myself like if I
had if I guess I met me like what I
liked me
what would I do what would I think what
I think I was neat you know what I think
I was tall what I think that I was
handsome you know what I think that I I
mean would I know if I were able to look
into my own eyes but I'd be able to like
see my truth set like another like
another dimension you know especially
since most of my life you know
especially growing up like I didn't have
any set a lot of self-worth so I was
most of my self-worth would come from
what other people thought of me you know
there was no you know the there was
nothing inside of me so everything that
I knew I had to get from the outside and
so I was so hyper aware of what other
people were constantly thinking because
I needed to be because I needed that
next second and that next minute and
that next you know just to know I knew I
was monitoring how I was and if I was
okay through moment to moment
interaction with others and what they
would give me back that's how I feel
about myself I was thinking like if if I
based my feelings off of what other
people thought of me and I saw myself
would I then like looking into my own
eyes would I be able to you know just
come full circle with with what
self-worth means and what it you know
and and just I get to another plateau in
thinking about that but ever just
fascinated me I left out of there
thinking like what the [ __ ] I never
thought about running into myself what I
think I had bad breath you know what I
think I had like a longneck or a regular
neck room you know what kind of us you
know a four out of ten kind of a mid
range lower you know lower mid-range
neck medium rare
because I've all you know I've had you
know my don't have a super long neck and
I don't think a lot of people in my
family we're not real look around us
some people have a long neck you know
when you see those people they're
looking for stuff and they can you know
look behind the sofa easier and they
don't lose their wallet probably as much
because they
you know they got that extra two inches
to look then the gays you know they
could see fruit easier if they read you
if they're looking for fruits but when
you have that limited neck man you kind
of you know you're stuck on your own
little bitty you know it's not really a
hilltop you just kind of stuck on you
know you kind of just hanging out on
your own cliffside you can't do a lot
when you got that limited kind of that
limited net and I come from a long line
of people with limited necks but yeah I
was just wondering if you saw yourself
and you looked in your own eyes would
you I don't know what we thought I mean
would your this whole world explode like
would you just know everything but I
like myself but I like just blew my mind
if there were infinite universes and it
just blew my mind man so I left out of
there I think with a little bit more
thinking you know and I think that
that's kind of what Joe Rogan does for
me is he makes me think a little bit
more and he makes me think sometimes I
want comfortable things you know he
makes me think outside of like the
confines of the comfortable confines of
things that you know these these
templates that I was raised in or raised
around or just that I saw you know it's
kind of like when you see remember when
you got that you got them colors when
you were a child and your mother took
you to the color shop and you got that
aid box you got that box eight hitters
you know that wrote that you know just
that little [ __ ] that ROYGBIV fiasco
you know you got that little eight pack
that 8-ball you know you got that eight
ball and suddenly some dude shows up
with that six staff follow-up box and
your [ __ ] dick blew out of your ears
remember that dude I remember my nuts
traveled up my body and looked out of my
I hold because I was just I
just shook by the fact that some man
suddenly had 56 more colors than I had
some boy I mean not a man they didn't
have any men in our class you know in
disguise or anything but that some boy I
was in it blew my mind and suddenly you
were doing different pictures and you
were thinking different things and you
you were like [ __ ] magenta I'm out here
on magenta and then and then and then
everything changed because then I would
see a you know maybe I would see a
somebody's shirt or hat or a you know I
would see a woman's head at church and
be like oh that's a magenta hat and
suddenly you know you have more elements
to put out into your template to put out
into your world and that's kind of I
think you know that's kind of what I
left out of Joe Rogan's podcast thinking
I left out of their actually just
thinking you know he makes me think and
I think he makes a lot of you know young
men and women think you know he's kind
of this dope-ass outer space male you
know marine kind of nah he's just
everything I don't know what he is man
it's almost like if you took a whole
timeline of existence and just took it
like that and put it all in the one
person it's like the past and you know
in the future and everything and he's
probably got moons
I bet dude I bet he has moons going
around him I bet there's a moon way off
in the distance that we don't even know
about that's just that you know just
that Rogen that Rogen moon but it was an
honor man it's an honor to go in there
you know it's just an honor you know
were like I don't know it made and it
made me fit you know I just felt like
accepted you know like he made me feel
accepted which for me is like a really
big thing you know like um you know like
I think a lot of my life I don't feel
that way
and so to go in and and I don't I don't
even think these are things that he's
you know outwardly doing like on purpose
I think someone is just his nature you
know I think in some ways he's like a
little bit of like that big brother that
like you know you know I had my brother
but my brother you know didn't live with
us and like you know and he you know and
he's had some you know he's had some
tough times even though I'll you know I
really love my brother and I'm you know
I don't think I've ever been prouder of
anybody in my whole life than him but uh
anyway damn boy this [ __ ] got me glee
can out my eyeballs dude you know I'm
saying I'm [ __ ] making salt water
dude I'm a damn I'm like a sixth grade
science experiment it but yeah I don't
know he just made me feel accepted and
just you know I don't know but I'm just
grateful man you know I'm just grateful
to be in an environment where I feel
inspired what's up guys sitting here
with this marijuana plant I think also
could be just a regular plant it could
be poison ivy brought about to smoke
myself in some itchy itchy just watch
another clip since you're already here
you know I'm saying